bei ihr sind die leute sind heute machen
wir machen ja mit mir und lukas ja sehr
gute begrüßung sand als ich nichts
anderes essbares gefunden habe bei
gaddafis aufgefordert habe habe ich
nämlich der körper vorgenommen und habe
ich mir code zu kommen und das habe ich
dann auf gegessen wenn die wüsste wie
wertvoll klopapier wurde mir das würde
ich auch eine option zur mir zu helfen
spaß habe ich damals immer einmal
englisch buch gegessen zu den wichtigen
themen komme ich gleich null aber auch
prinz marcus von anhalt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich habe eine zeitlang mit dem spiel so
persönliche gespräche gehabt
persönliche gespräche mit dem döner
spieß er hatte ein
und ich dachte sandra wer schlimme die
im englisches buch alter meine träume
sind schon vor vielen jahren geplant wie
fini an genau wie alt das ist falsch
geschrieben ich schwöre ihm fehlen
dieser m synapsen oder wie das doch mal
ist synapsen ja empfiehlt ebenfalls
fehlt ihm im gehirn der ist nicht ganz
der ist nicht ganz beisammen weiß es ist
ein schwieriges thema
ich bin kaputt ich kann nicht mehr
dazu muss ich kurz was sagen und zwar
sander vor einigen tagen ihre terrasse
fertiggestellt zu hause und jetzt meine
sind im sommer einmal draußen dass wir
das wir selbst dann auch sein also wieso
zerstören von wespen mücken wird es
heiss wie man sich wehrt kommt ein
angreifer gewalttätiger immer gewalt aus
dem weg gehen einfach sagen halt stopp
jetzt hole ich das gesicht ist richtig
gut klappen erna dein bier cloud alter
sehen wenn jemand kommt noch nicht sagt
ich rufe die polizei was willst du
machen wenn einer kommt der ein bisschen
gefährlich aussieht bevor der mich
ankommt box nicht den alltag zeigt mal
wieder den boxen würde so presse liebe
freunde ich hoffe dass sie gut durch
diese schwierige zeit kommt und sende
euch meinen besten grüße der typ ist
halt auch echt so ein 60-jähriger
gefangen im körper eines 20 jährigen
philipp am tor
er ist der jüngste cdu-abgeordnete
sandra du bist jüngsten arbeitslose in
deutschland
ich habe geschwitzt gar nicht viele
plätze schaffte
ich hab sogar zehn punkte plan wieder
klar geworden was ist das ein spiel
gekauft
das sogar ernsthaft gefragt was den
spieler ist ja was denkst du was das für
ein spiel ist
[Musik]
luca bist du noch anhören
lukas wahrscheinlich oder hochnehmen
alter vor allem von was gibt es
mittlerweile noch kein filter ich heute
gesehen es gibt ein wer wird millionär
filters ist so krank einfahren
du wirst du nicht mehr über die null
euro kommen ich habe diese skeptisch
oder so gemacht
ich habe fleißig power pop ließ damit
nicht vertan
[Musik]
gerade hier schon mal in einem podcast
folge gesagt warum will die welt dass
wir pflanzen in die welt versprühen mit
wir co2 bilden neo 2 ghz damit wir ccd
damit die methan in zwei verwickeln
verwandeln bis 40 wird glauben heute ich
habe tatsächlich den am morgen gefunden
[Musik]
bei diesen nicht lachen challenges
verliere ich meinen glauben an die
menschheit bitte beleidigt mich okay ich
habe es verdient beleidigt zu werden
aber gibt bitte nicht auf mutter geht
bitte nicht auf mutter das mache ich mit
deiner mario genau die stellung
hat er wirklich in einem video gesagt
geht auf mich aber geht nicht auf meine
mutter und dann nein nein nein sandra
nein was hat der ahnt was ist das ist
das
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das ist ein esel und das ist der
türkische präsident
[Gelächter]
ich wünschte echte erste dienstag wäre
am sonntag mit das ergibt keinen sinn
ein gesicht
[Musik]
nein
positiv franzosen konsum luca ferro
wahnsinn ist
was soll ich dir sagen sagt er in satz
auf deutlich über sechs jahre
französisch ich wohne in köln die lotto
toto cologne nein das heißt ja
bietigheimer du kannst kein französisch
natürlich hatte französisch fünf jahre
die sander was heißt auf französisch
mein name ist sandra ich bin 20 jahre
alt und bin dumm hat weiß ich nicht und
ich bin dumm mehr kann ich nicht
[Musik]
wenn ich das bist du nach sachen feiern
das ist nur traurig tigger das ist nicht
was ist das ist wirklich einfach nur
traurig nein
[Musik]
ich frag mich was er damit bewirken will
sich doch nur zum affen aber er hat doch
schon er ist doch also er hat er hat
doch schon eine menge geld was ich meine
warum machen wir das ich glaube wäre ich
multi millionären oder soda ich will
trotzdem noch hier straße tun aber alles
zu seiner zeit
[Musik]
also wenn du im bett liegt abends und du
denkst du ja ich gehe jetzt mal ein
detektor wir erlangen bleibst du da drin
mindestens eine dreiviertelstunde okay
ich dachte ich werde mich wäre mit so 20
25 minuten schon krass dabei aber tik
tok es wirklich so süchtig machen
bei youtube ist es so wenn ihr video
drückst du weg arbeit tik tok das geht
so schnell und weißt du was mir nicht
gefällt was deine tecdax gut boden mein
baby
hergelaufen ist dass das ist das ist es
ein paar mut
seither gelaufen ich doch das war nicht
ich verkleide ich dachte jetzt es kommt
was übels witziges ich hab mir egal ich
hab ja ich hab da die ich habe schon den
weißen rauch gesehen hab ich schon
die karte basiert gibt dürfte
geschriebene mein handy ist mir volle
kanne eine charaktersache mieter suchen
und irgendeiner das klippen und auf
instagram hochladen dieser noch nicht
uns erschrocken
das wäre wahnsinn danke an der stelle wo
ich das heute wieder ist allerdings ob
werden meine lieben freunde mir hat das
gerade echt den rest gegeben dieses
komische erschreckend was war das sandra
lava kläger du bist du bist du bist in
müssen so dachte wenn euch das heutige
video auf jeden fall gefallen hat das
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem ihr da
schreibt das gerne und in die kommentare
welche videos wir im nächsten teil nicht
lachen reagieren sollen und jetzt
befinden wir uns auch schon einen kart
männer lieben freunde hier oben ist ein
smiley ein gelände werde er darauf
geklagt den kosmos main kanal abonnieren
und hier ist ein video verlinkt was
soeben auf meine zweite kanal online
gegangen ist
das ist nämlich eine neue challenge und
das nehme ich jetzt mit sandra auf also
ich weiß noch nicht worum es geht aber
klickt das auf jeden fall gern mal an